there are so many women that really do
advocate for not going 50/50 right and
for me I definitely went through like my
well I'm a feminist I shouldn't have an
issue going 50/50 face right when I was
younger but recently I started to
realize just how difficult it was
accepting going 50-50 with men and I
have come to the realization that it is
because even as a feminist it is the
only only benefit women reap out of the
patriarchy you're literally trying to
rid me of the only benefit I get out of
the patriarchy the only like think about
it for a second by your telling we are a
patriarchal society and the patriarchy
is an abject evil you say and yet you
wish to extract whatever benefits you
can from it this thing is evil and
terrible and should be dismantled but I
also want to reap its Rewards